thank you to the hardcore dedicated fans
who slept on you know concrete they're
always impressed and amazed that the
turnout and the passion that you guys
have yeah so obviously he's been bit
shake up we wanted to address that
quickly but we don't want to take too
much time because we're here to have fun
and look at some cool stuff you guys
haven't seen yet but yeah about the the
you know pulling it off the channel and
moving to digital exclusively you know
it's part of this huge sea change really
in the whole industry I mean you guys
I'm sure you've seen articles about
cable cutters and you know we're seeing
Digital streaming you know companies
doing their own content and winning
Emmys and all sorts of stuff so
obviously we're in the midst of this big
change and things have changed just for
us between when we did avatar between
2005 and 2008 when those air and then
when we came back on the air in 2012 you
know when when book 1 of Korra came out
it did it did pretty good numbers on TV
but its online presence was just insane
not only the chatter from all the fans
all over the world but the actual
numbers in terms of digital downloads
Digital streaming they've just been huge
and as this show is gone
along by the time we got to book 2 the
numbers of the the digital streaming
they greatly outweighed what was
happening on the channel it's no secret
that avatar and especially Korra
our typical kind of Nickelodeon fare
so they had a kind of a hard time trying
to fit it into their into their
programming but basically the book tooth
finale
the numbers were insane they were when
they streamed it when it went on Nick
comm it was the biggest streaming event
they had had the entire year and that
show for digital downloads was all right
you know that that season was amazing so
and then obviously as you've seen not so
much on the channel so it's just it's
just part of this shift over it
definitely caught us by surprise that
wasn't necessarily done in the smoothest
way and that was sending too many of you
and costs as well so yeah we're you know
we're it's moving over to digital this
is actually it was a plan that's kind of
in place earlier they changed course and
they went back to it so it all kind of
happened in a little bit of a messy way
but thanks for sticking with us the show
is not canceled yeah he's right
to understand
really has no effect on what the show is
or the stories we're telling because
we're we finished the writing for the
series we've finished all the
pre-production and we're just doing post
and studio mares finishing the animation
so other than it not being on the
Nickelodeon main channel nothing is
changed you're going to get to see it
which is the important thing and you can
actually they're going to start putting
it online starting next Friday so I'll
just first and then there's going to be
a new episode every week after that
until August 22nd when they do the
two-part season 3 finale will be out by
the end of the year so yeah you will
though so let's have fun let's get out
of it so we're gonna we're gonna show
you guys an episode that is not aired
as I've known to say it's a doozy I know
some of you it's we don't know how to
make a show where it's entertaining and
exciting but nothing bad ever happens
what's your ad did it yet so without a
hope you enjoyed this episode
yeah this is this is written by Josh and
Josh Hamilton and Josh here cowl neck
directed Lee Thunder let's go I know
this is super self-indulgence but real
quick just watching that and you know
everybody on this panel has had the good
fortune of being here in a room like
this before except for John Michael
Higgins and Mindy sterling could you
just give them one more quick welcome
No we know we know they fun was was
missed in book two a bit but you but
you're back I'm back let's go down long
I've got a couple questions for you guys
Korowai these are these are some
questions that fans submitted online and
someone named John was wondering for
Janet how would you rate Cora's job as
the avatar so far how do you think she's
doing well I'm saying that this is a
question that I get asked a lot at the
cons that I do and sometimes it's put
really nicely and sometimes it's put
grumpily um sometimes people like DUI
cora um but you know I think this just
the episode that we got a chance to
watch is such a great example to me of
you know just she has some classic
horror moments where she gets a little
snappish but um it's such a great
example of how much she's come to
understand that she may be the Avatar
but that doesn't mean that she can do
her job alone and it's just so exciting
to see you know the team together and
and so I think you know again she's
she's on her journey you know she's on
the arc that Mike and Brian had always
envisioned for her and I'm proud of her
and she's infuriating and wonderful and
strong and very human and
and David we have a question about about
the voice-acting process and what that's
like and when you guys get the scripts
like do you have time to read it
beforehand or and are you guys as
emotionally compromised by these
storylines as as the fans seem to be
when they see the shows oh well when I
first started to show I would just rush
the script to find Michael
my favorite is Michael's life my life my
life and as it became a fan I read the
script so we got the scripts I think the
night before right usually we just get
the scripts the night before we come in
and record and you know and and then we
get in there and we usually sometimes we
have the whole cast together when we're
all available which is great we're all
in the same room we got mics in front of
us and we've got our lines and it's it's
tremendous and it's a lot of fun awesome
and we'll shout out to our voice
director and Ray Romano Andrea Romano
sir three bags and say show so in the
first episode of book three we saw that
korra and asami are now like BFFs right
have you seen Korra and song is like
friendship developing and seeing them
like start as rivals but now they're
kind of friends and stuff honey
you enjoyed playing that
love it at my parents were actually
especially fond of that scene in the car
they had seen the episode before me and
they were like oh my god cornice obvious
show to you like what does it take so
long sometimes I forget what happens and
I'm surprised by the story lines already
know um but I'm happy I at any instance
where two girls can like not let a guy
get in between them I think it's a good
thing they're maturing um there is a guy
between you two right now right in the
middle so yeah no I'm happy for them I
think they're strongly together and they
make team avatar better for it
Amano has to deal with the office nights
and we've gotten over that so yeah
that's good get over it lock up the
tables have turned
and uh mr. Higgins welcome thank you so
since you came in and book two uh you
know one of my favorites the humor he
brings every every time he comes is
amazing and this fan thought you rate
the most tactic that captivating
character of the bunch oh no offense to
Janet in the others
they're one point out what do you think
makes Varrick a truly unique character
in the Avatar universe well first of all
I want to say how thrilled I am to be a
part of this universe all of a sudden I
I I'm amazed of what I was seeing today
right in front of me I honestly thought
I was going to be doing a press thing
with about 20 people in the room and you
can put many zeros behind out of her
they had really pleased to be here thank
you yeah well you know when my agent
said hey you know that doing this is
Nickelodeon you should go over there
it's a
airbending thing it's and I was a great
you know it's not really part of my gig
usually I do it so I get to fly around
and you know bend cars with my face and
that sort of thing no you're just sort
of a [ __ ] talks too much
that's what I do all day long that's
every job no I think part of the fun of
varrock particularly seeing now yet
another episode is that he does sort of
bridge the gap between our world and and
the other world in an interesting way he
sort of part you know Rupert Murdoch and
Thomas Edison you know both of the clown
all rolled together and I think he's
captivating because he has so little the
respect basically will part for old
magic and Wonder and power and
mightiness that's going on around him
it's a it's he regards it as either
helpful or not helpful to him and what
he needs to do so it's a fascinating
character and he is constantly
surprising me and I think he surprises
the writers is and I'm always it's
always have fun to show up and in the
room and see this odd completely odd
paragraph I have to say
it's like okay here we go
I remember one episode particularly that
I liked I think it's later in the in the
series though careful no spray where he
talks about his childhood it is beyond
belief so we are that's awesome mindy
welcome welcome yeah in real life I miss
it's really like cool you guys are
amazing and awesome and some of you
slept overnight to get in here right
so so what's your favorite part of the
voicing win and do you have any
similarities in your personality
whittling oh well I think for me the
best part of doing this character is
this is an amazing strong woman who is
fearless and powerful and feminine yeah
and hot looking you know and it is not
afraid to take you know control in
charge and and really does have this
amazing you know facet to to everything
she does I love love plate all right
is she a little bit like me I think all
of our characters have a little
similarities to our personalities
ourselves I am not that strong I am not
that powerful but I am that feminine and
it is and I love playing she's not mean
I get a lot of I play a lot of really
nasty women and she's not she's just a
very matter-of-fact and she's there to
protect the avatar and aura and so she's
very motherly and
and it has lots of bad agent issues
which I do now this question I found
very funny so I'm going to ask you guys
uh for John Michael Higgins and Mindy
Varrick and Lin that somehow end up on a
blind date with each other what happens
the two single people on the town what's
going well it's a show up where they had
a couple of drinks a big problem about
well he make me laugh is what I want
yeah well who's going to be on top
personally a conflict and Willie go all
night maybe hey thanks kids
very interesting date evening there we
go Applebee's I love it
alright so we got a really special
question here and I'll give credit to
Bridal Mira for asking this you you've
inspired us so he had a question that
said can we have voice actors sing
secret tunnel as their character
which I think we can do that but before
we do that I want to invite a special
guest to the panel oh my god as the
voice of Bobby
into stage but yeah we also need your
help with this
so as you know
TV play the original character Chong
from a book - of Avatar
all right there is a song thanks
everybody
give the clip and charm Chong's gonna
sing John Johnson bro okay I wrote
Oakland so sing along everybody story
about a secret pact yeah this is real or
a legend
all right we're watching pending itself
Oh
the next couple
Oh
laughs diameter I love that guy does a
coup out I hang out with that guy Wi-Fi
device on his back in plays the drums
while looking up at the sky oh right
hmm alright thank you so much actors for
answering those questions and singing
the song we're going to show you guys
some cool art work real quick from book
three we go to visuals there on the
screen and so what happening
go ahead we were there there we go okay
so we know you were all dying to know
what it would have looked like had boomy
got the sweater on boom Jim hey so yeah
that's it that's all the artwork on
really nice dude
here's the first concept piece I did for
see here you know after books wanted to
I thought you know Tarlac and a lot kind
of looked the same so I wanted to do
something very different so we're sort
of an MMA fighter kind of catch
wrestling yeah
so wanted them to be kind of bulky and
have a different look this is reuse
concept that he did after mine of course
complete with Ruiz crazy color
combinations how are you are you here
buddy genius so I did a constant we know
he's going to be in prison for a long
time they probably didn't let them groom
so it's gonna grow some hair and Ryu did
these incredible expression sheets of
him when he's busting the buddy out of
the barge and they you see his hair
metal top here what's what he's gonna
look like for rest the season so you can
see now if you ever think his ears look
strange like maybe they didn't draw well
that was actually intentional he's
supposed to have cauliflower here from a
career quite so so there is is honest my
first concept for name always I don't
have any tattoos but obviously
electronic tattooed characteristic from
egg and ghazan and so this reuse
concepts are expression sheets of his
head and then I had to work out the
tattoos it's always tough because it's
hard to do kind of graphic patterns
moving over shapes you know keeping them
consistent but these were fun to do and
then make mauve favorite character of
ours to conceive of and design and this
is based on she's just basically my
friend Michi but Michi does have arms of
flesh of but not of water and then so
here he is incredible expression sheets
for her and then some of my the model
she just kind of explaining the
different things she could do with her
her malleable water arms and then leave
another fun one
to design this is Angela Muller are you
here Angela over there so Angelo's as an
old friend and great character designer
who worked on Avatar The Last Airbender
and when she was gonna work on core I
said hey take a stab at this this like
firebending assassin and so she did this
crazy kind of Elizabeth cylinder looking
character and I liked it and this is
some quad head she did for that and I
said but let's make her 6/8 so this was
my my version of it based on her design
and then we kind of finished it together
and we have our next combustion bender
and so then when they're busting out
fully we had to like give them winter
costumes so we kind of like winterized
everybody and Christi sang our other
character designer and Angie returned
again you know different concepts and
Angie turned in this one person here
she's I got you know like really
nonchalant I've got some alternate ones
too for you to consider
we were gonna go the one on the right
he's talking a little too hard animes oh
oh how could I unsee that so damn you
did as you know is he here is voiced by
legendary Henry Rollins as we like to
call him the most interesting man in the
world he's born many hats but he's you
know he built his career as a legendary
punk singer so Ryu did this awesome I
see you spit off I don't know about you
guys
so then where you have the metal clan
suyin this family which was really fun
doing this Art Deco city and our type of
fashion and jewelry us this was my first
concept for her and that's what we ended
up with when she was in color and her
husband in guitar you only see a little
bit so far he's the architect and guitar
jr. I swear that that expression looks
like David Schwimmer to me you only see
the target in your very briefly in the
doorway but yeah he does exist so he he
works with his at a lot in the city and
then who on in kids
real exceptional
there's one very fun and then we've got
his final color it was really fun doing
all the different variations on this
kind of like utopia Art Deco outfits
Opel was really fun to design I did her
original concept and then we got her
color model she's kind of like a little
flapper and then winging way aka Tom
oxen Seema
we've got of the mirror image twins
you'll notice their hair parts opposite
and half their jewelry other ill-will
doodads or opposite of each other
they're fun they really remind me of
Josh our writer kind of a like cool bro
and then it's so tiny in the show but I
wanted to show you the sues circus photo
from when she joined the circus
so that's soohyun on the top there
and it was a fun way to get to see the
little babe they still have a little
baby platypus bear Kristin saying did
that and then the family photo
I hadn't had chains post that yet but I
always loved seeing family photos for
these guys who on doesn't like getting
his picture - yeah
so yeah that's the art and now we're
going to show you a really awesome treat
we have studio some represented from CMU
here Jimmy are you here
videoman long after we've been working
with Jamie I love that part mm Three's
old friend cars and and we kind of you
know been there and helped him build his
own animation studio it's been amazing
working with them yeah and they're I
mean every this episode was just one
example of the many amazing action
scenes and emotional scenes they're just
good at everything so we're so glad that
they're doing all of book 3 and all
before I mean we just want to mention
real quick since the end of book 2 when
they came back to the production they've
been helped out by their friends a
studio rev an awesome studio that works
alongside with them so they've already
been working helping out with a bunch of
the episodes so I just want thanks to do
right for their great work to some kinds
of testings alongside the final footage
so you can see you know it's always nice
to see the actual hand-drawn and look of
the the drawings and then you'll see at
the end is a couple scenes from a later
episode so a slight sneak peek but
they're all the pencil tests but
everyone today our amazing crew and our
amazing cast and a shout out our awesome
producer Karen Malik who
wrangle this all got this thing done in
a reasonable amount of time so we
appreciate it yeah and unfortunately
these these panels go back to fence I
already that's great
Thank You Pat I want to thank everybody
who really I mean camped out and slept
in yeah and everybody waited in line we
thank you guys so much for coming here
it's awesome you guys are the best